[Music]
good afternoon everyone welcome to
another in our series of Compton
lectures let me give you a little bit of
context about the content lectures
before introducing today's speaker the
Compton lectures were established just
over 50 years ago in 1957 to honor one
of my predecessors mi t--'s president
Carl Taylor Compton who had died three
years before Karl Taylor Compton guided
MIT for almost a quarter of a century
from 1930 until his death in 1954 he's
recruited to MIT as president from
Princeton in 1930 and continued to serve
as president until 1949 and then served
as chairman of the corporation our board
of trustees he was a transformative
figure in MIT history the Compton
lectures honor his wide-ranging
intelligence and curiosity they were
begun and I quote from the founding
documents to bring to MIT some of the
great minds on the world scene and they
surely have from the great physicist
Niels Bohr who gave the inaugural
Compton lecture to Senator Edward
Kennedy who spoke here last spring
president Compton himself was known for
his high intelligence his deep knowledge
his integrity his thoughtfulness and his
ability to see the future so it's
extremely fitting that we should honor
his legacy with the speaker who embodies
these same exceptional qualities senator
jeff Bingaman harry truman used to say
that it's amazing how much you can
accomplish if you don't care who gets
the credit and there could not be a more
fitting headline for senator Bingaman's
legislative career born and raised in
new mexico he served as the state's
United States Senator since he was first
elected in 1982
in that role he has consistently taken
the long view speaking not only for the
people of his state but also tackling
the broadest questions of our national
interest with an open mind and
importantly a steady moral compass the
people of the state of New Mexico
clearly know that they have good thing
when they see it in the last election he
won by with 71% of the vote in the
Senate he's built a reputation for calm
persistent bipartisan leadership on
three subjects that endear him to MIT
first on American competitiveness and
its major drivers innovation science and
technology second he's been a proponent
for stronger science and math education
and third one of the reasons we're very
excited to welcome him to campus is his
work on energy policy including the
challenges and opportunities of clean
energy the topic that looks bored today
having met with the senator a couple of
times I can tell you that he understands
perhaps better than any other government
leader what it takes to promote
innovation in every part of the economy
and especially in the realm of clean
energy a few years ago many of you will
remember the National Academy of
Sciences produced a report that we call
The Gathering Storm as I was rising
above the Gathering Storm which
galvanized action in Washington around
America's lagging competitiveness in
science and technology although you
won't find senator Bingaman's
fingerprints directly on that report
they came together entirely thanks to
his vision and persistence in concert
with senators Dominica and Alexander not
surprisingly then senator Bingaman also
took the lead in passing the America
COMPETES legislation last fall which
calls for renewed and major investments
in federal R&D and in science education
he has been an outspoken advocate for
stem cell research understanding that
without looser federal guidelines
American scientists may well be left
behind as chair of the Senate committee
Committee on Energy and Natural
Resources a senator Bingaman also
spearheaded the congressional effort to
pass major energy legislation in 2007
and he authored one of the Senate's most
important climate change cap-and-trade
bills in short some of the most complex
problems that face us as a nation in
these he is leading the country to
thoughtful creative farsighted solutions
and we are all extremely grateful for
his leadership now
I understand from his staff that Senator
Bingaman does not like to have a fuss
made over him he was described as
someone who not only carries his own
suitcase but will carry yours as well
nevertheless without his permission I
wouldn't invite you all to help me make
a fuss in welcoming senator Bingaman to
MIT
thank you very much dr. Hockfield the
president Hockfield thank you very much
for that overly generous introduction
and let me start just by making the
obvious point that our nation is the
world leader in science and technology
and innovation and the students here and
the faculty here at MIT deserve much of
the credit for that anyone who pays
attention to our energy problems and how
those are being addressed knows that if
we in this country have anything akin to
a war room where energy challenges are
being confronted it's right here at MIT
Karl Compton who dr. Hockfield was
referring to himself said nowhere in the
country is such is there such a
concentration of scientific and
engineering laboratories and personnel
and that's obvious to anyone who spent
any time here
I compliment president Hockfield and all
of you who have been working on this MIT
Energy Initiative and I particularly
thank president Hockfield for the
generous invitation and the overly
generous introduction so it's an honor
for me to be here one of the greatest
lessons I've learned over the years is
to seek advice from people who know more
about a subject than I do and one of
those people whose advice I sought
before coming here to Cambridge today
was your former MIT president Chuck vest
who is now of course the president of
the National Academy of Engineering in
Washington he urged me to say a few
words about the factors that have
resulted in me a lawyer and politician
being here in front of you
talking about science technology and
energy policy and and being interested
and involved in those issues the most
important factor was probably my
father's lifelong commitment to science
both my parents were teachers and my my
mother taught elementary school my
father was the chemistry professor and
head of the science department at
Western New Mexico University in my
hometown of Silver City New Mexico
there's no way you can grow up in a
house with a chemistry professor without
developing some appreciation for the
importance of science
another factor undoubtedly was my uncle
he was heavily involved in the politics
of our state
he ran the political campaigns for a
long time New Mexico senator Clinton
Anderson so both my exposure to my
father's career in science and
engineering and my exposure to politics
through my uncle's avocation came
together to bring me to the Senate and
those influences are probably also
responsible for my focused attention on
the role that government and Science and
Technology can can play in helping us
meet our energy challenge I know many of
you have similar influences in your
lives as you move forward with your
education and your choice of a future
career I hope you'll consider ways that
you can use your MIT education to
address the great challenges that face
our society in this century government
at all levels but especially in
Washington will very much need to have
people with your qualifications and
ability if we're going to understand and
respond intelligently to these
challenges when we talk about energy
challenges what are we really focused on
the energy challenge that we recognize
today I believe is very different from
and more encompassing than what we
recognized as our energy challenge even
a few years ago until fairly recently at
least in Washington our energy challenge
was seen largely as the need to reduce
dependence on foreign oil for the past
quarter century we've seen the amount of
oil that we import grow substantially
and although relatively little has been
done to to counter that trend that issue
of imported foreign oil has dominated
energy debate in Washington
dependence on foreign oil remains a
major concern but today I think we see
our challenge our energy challenge as
much larger than that and in many ways
very different different in nature
different in scale and certainly more
urgent the energy challenge we see today
is a global challenge it's not a
national challenge it's to change the
way that the world produces and stores
and distributes and uses energy so as to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions it's to
shift not just our own economy but the
global economy from dependence on
combustion of fossil fuels to use of non
emitting energy sources with the
concentration of greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere on a trajectory to
unacceptable levels our sense of urgency
to take action has risen as well simply
stated it's not enough to commit to
reducing greenhouse gas emissions
beginning in 2025 we need to act and we
need to act now with respect to the
scale of the challenge it is immense
we and other nations in the world will
need to overhaul the existing energy
infrastructure on which we depend and
that infrastructure did not develop
overnight 200 years ago the combustion
of fossil fuels primarily coal produced
the steam that turned the turbines that
powered the Industrial Revolution today
our planet has more than 50,000 coal
burning power plants accounting for
nearly 1/3 of greenhouse gas emissions
worldwide the normal rate of turnover
for this infrastructure is at least 40
to 50 years 100 years ago the decision
was made to power our transportation
sector by burning petroleum-based fuels
in an internal combustion engine rather
than through the use of electric motors
and batteries today we have over 600
million vehicles using some version of
that internal combustion engine
producing 14% of greenhouse gas
emissions worldwide
but our challenge is not limited to just
the power plants and the vehicles that
we drive we live in a world of growing
demand for energy as billions of people
are rising out of poverty is that the
man grows it will require new energy
production capacity and today that new
capacity generally consists of more
coal-fired power plants with the same
high carbon emission carbon dioxide
emissions as our current energy
infrastructure just a couple of weeks
ago India announced that it's building a
new 4 gigawatt coal burning power plant
complex these plants will emit more than
23 million tons of co2 each year and the
justification is that the need to bring
electricity to one of the world's
poorest regions is more pressing than
the need to limit carbon dioxide from
burning fuels and this is the least
expensive way that they know to do it
it's difficult to argue against that
rationale when most of us here have
never known a life without electricity
so as we struggle to develop
alternatives to our current energy
infrastructure we must recognize that in
order to achieve sustainable use of
those alternatives worldwide they need
to be cost competitive so that they are
the option of first choice to accomplish
all this we will need both a revolution
and technology and major changes in our
economy our past technological choices
are clearly inadequate for the future
the solutions we need can only come from
new technologies and if the challenge of
developing those new technologies and
implementing them worldwide is immense
so too are the opportunities afforded by
tackling this problem in the right way
if we see our most pressing
environmental problems as an opportunity
to reassert US leadership in science and
technology and innovation we have the
potential not only to solve those
problems but also to revitalize our
research and development Enterprise to
rebuild our manufacturing base in the
process but how do we go about
accelerating the development and the
widespread use of new technologies to
address our energy challenge one
promising place to start is to adopt
policies that will put a price on
emitting co2 and other greenhouse gases
by levying a cost on the putting of
greenhouse gases in the air we will
accelerate the private sector
development and use of technologies to
avoid and to minimize greenhouse gas
emissions in the Senate we're working on
a design for a regulatory framework in
the form of a cap-and-trade system that
will recognize the real costs of
continued emission of greenhouse gases
and shift development toward low carbon
production the last few years we've seen
a dramatic increase in private sector
entrepreneurs who want to develop clean
energy technologies if we're successful
in putting a price on the emission of
greenhouse gases that will stimulate
private sector involvement even more the
proper design of a cap-and-trade system
for greenhouse gas emissions is not the
subject of my talk today but I do want
to just say in passing that it is not a
simple matter having been in the Senate
for 25 years I can assure you that in
Congress we have the ability to design
and enact a totally unworkable system
and without the help of some of the this
country's best minds we could wind up
doing just that
so while putting a price on co2
emissions is an essential part of the
solution it's not the only tool we
should be using to resolve the problem
we should also change the way that we
pursue technology development and
deployment it's here that I want to
focus my talk today I want to cite five
main areas where our policies to support
technology development and use have
fallen short I think they're right up
here on the screen first the need to
support our science and technology
enterprise I'll say a few words about
that second the need to set priorities
for energy technology development and
use third the need to sustain a support
the support for those research and
development priorities fourth the need
for a long term regulatory and tax
framework that will promote development
of new technologies and fifth the need
for a strategy on how we can create the
high wage jobs involved in the
manufacture of these clean energy
technologies our first key failing is in
our support for basic science and
engineering throughout this country that
the best recent analysis is the one that
president Hockfield referred referred to
the report from the National Academies
rising above the Gathering Storm that
report was a well supported wake-up call
for policy makers on the need for major
sustained support for basic sciences in
this country we in Washington are
beginning to respond while we don't have
major progress to report as yet I
believe we will make significant
progress in the months and years ahead
one aspect of our anemic and unreliable
support for the basic science and
engineering Enterprise in the country
has been the anemic and unreliable
support for energy related Science and
Technology Development and that brings
me to the second point on the chart we
fail to set priorities among the
promising energy technology
that would lower our greenhouse gas
emissions you can find government
reports on climate change technologies
the Department of Energy put out such a
report in 2006 that it labeled as a
strategic plan but the report was
basically a shopping list of viable
technologies there were no concrete
goals no roadmaps for making progress no
timelines for development such reports
are not entirely without value but what
we have nationally today is far from
being a strategy it is far from adequate
in my view to address the challenge that
we have as a nation what we need is to
formulate a strategic research and
development plan that maps out a
prioritized set of technological goals
the steps that are needed to achieve
those goals and the time in which those
goals should be met I'm not talking
about a document that would limit
scientific or technological exploration
in other areas but instead a road map
with broad highways along which we could
ensure that science and technology
support would be forthcoming any energy
research and development roadmap that we
design will have to have plenty of on
ramps and off ramps to incorporate new
knowledge new understanding and
breakthroughs that will inevitably occur
Japan has recently begun to move along
the path of developing such a strategic
plan with their release last month of of
the cool earth innovative energy
technology program and we have a copy of
the the chart that they have recently
released this document identifies 21
areas of technology development which
were chosen to meet two criteria first
each is expected to deliver substantial
reductions in carbon dioxide emissions
in the world by 2050 and second each is
a technology area in which Japan
believes it can lead the world
technology roadmaps are being formulated
for each of the 21 technologies giving
R&D direction and milestones on
performance with timeline
timelines toward achieving long-term
goals perhaps the closest parallel we
have to the Japanese priority-setting
effort as a project to identify the
Grand Challenges for engineering in the
21st century this is this was described
in a report recently by the National
Academy of Engineering
among the Grand Challenges that were
identified are two of the 21 technology
areas covered in the Japanese innovative
technology program specifically making
solar energy economical and developing
carbon sequestration methods while
there's a significant effort underway at
our National Laboratories our national
academies to determine us research and
development needs in the energy area
it's also clear I believe that the
systematic setting and maintenance of
priorities for energy technology
development is not something that we
have committed to at the highest levels
of our government so what do I propose
as a solution to this I believe we
should take five steps the first would
be to establish overall responsibility
at those highest levels of our
government for such an effort much of
what's covered on the previous chart of
innovative technologies is funded by the
Department of Energy but a number of key
areas belong to other departments of
government such as the Department of
Commerce even the Secretary of Energy
and the Secretary of Commerce have a
difficult time getting the research
funding that they need out of the White
House Budget Office which is run by the
Office of Management and Budget so I
believe what we need to do is make the
president's science advisor give him
more authority one way is to provide
provide that enhanced authority would be
to direct that the president's science
advisor hold a concurrent appointment at
the deputy director level in the Office
of Management and Budget that would
ensure that the same person with
responsibility for overall science and
technology policy in government has some
real authority to ensure that the fun
to support that science and technology
make it into the federal budget as a
second step the president's science
adviser armed with his enhanced
authority or her enhanced authority
should work with the key departments in
the National Academies to come up with a
manageable set of energy technology
areas that promise to aid us in meeting
our energy needs and substantially
reducing greenhouse gas emissions and in
the coming decades some of these will be
technology areas that the Japanese or
others have identified others will be
new to the list a third step in each of
the chosen technology areas a working
group of academic and government and
laboratory and industry should be
convened and a broad roadmap developed
to chart the way forward and
responsibility for pursuit of that
roadmap in each technology area should
be assigned to a particular department
or a particular agency fourth to ensure
that an adequate degree of sustained
focus and an adequate level of funding
is provided the president should be
required to submit to Congress with his
budget early each year a separate
document detailing the funds being
requested of the Congress in support of
each technology area across the agencies
of government and finally to ensure that
the area is being pursued continue to be
those that hold the greatest promise the
National Academy should be directed to
prepare an updated analysis of energy
technology priorities every five years
we already do something very similar
with our defense policy by requiring the
so-called quadrennial defense review
every four years MIT has already begun
to take the lead in prioritizing
promising technologies with its reports
on the future of nuclear power on coal
geothermal energy I'm looking forward
also to the completion of the other
works you're doing on solar energy on
natural gas as I understand it your
reports have a real impact on what
happens in Washington in fact it's
precisely because of the future of
geothermal energy
report that we have an enhanced
geothermal research and development
program at the Department of Energy
today this graph shows the lack of
consistent support for geothermal energy
development in recent years in early
2006 the president proposed a budget for
2007 with zero funding for geothermal
energy research he did the same in early
2007 for the 2008 budget but when the
MIT report drew the attention of
Congress in 2007 to the importance and
to the promise of research on geothermal
energy Congress responded and as a
result the funding level went back to
twenty million dollars for 2008 the
Department of Energy then took note of
that report took note of the interest
that Congress had evidenced and
reinitiated its requests for funding in
2009 but as we've learned from hard
experience it's one thing to set
priorities and begin pursuing them it's
a very different thing to sustain that
effort what brings me that that brings
me to the third major policy failing
that I wanted to mention from the
earlier list our record for sustaining
the effort at critical technology
development has been poor once we set
the course why aren't we able to stick
with that one obvious problem is that
each new administration feels they need
to pursue something new instead of
sticking with the difficult blocking and
tackling required the move will move the
ball down the field we allow our
attention and effort to be deflected we
comfort ourselves with the notion that
some Hail Mary pass will nevertheless
allow us to score a touchdown to this
point our stop and stop effort stop and
start efforts with regard to geothermal
development unfortunately have also been
matched by similar efforts in the
development of vehicle technology On
February 10 of 1970 before many in this
room were born President Nixon announced
the following and a special message to
Congress I am inaugurating a program
Marshall both governments and private
research with the goal of producing an
unconventional pike unconventionally
powered pollution-free automobile within
five years that was 1977 years later in
1977 President Carter announced his
program for reinventing the car 16 years
after that in 1993 President Clinton
announced his partnership for a new
generation of vehicles ten years after
that in 2003 President Bush announced
his push for a freedom car so
identifying the priority is obviously
not enough it's also necessary to
develop a consensus on how to proceed
and that that has to be a consensus that
will survive from one administration and
one Congress to the next the development
of a national strategic plan for energy
technology development together with
regular updating of that plan will go a
long way toward avoiding this stop and
start approach that has plagued us in
the past the fourth major failing from
the earlier list that I had up there
fourth major failing in our Science and
Technology Policy happens after we
discover or develop new science and
engineering at places like MIT we don't
have long-term regulatory and tax
policies to promote development and
manufacture and widespread use of those
technologies as Germany has shown in the
areas of wind and solar providing such
long-term policies can create a booming
renewables industry in this country
we've seen a different story play out
utility regulation and rate setting are
have historically been the job of public
regulatory commissions at the state
level and while some states have enacted
progressive policies such as a renewable
portfolio standard and net metering many
states have not we've tried for the last
three congresses to enact a renewable
portfolio standard at the national level
but these efforts have met
resistance from utilities and from the
current administration similarly in the
area of tax incentives for increased
efficiency and renewable technologies
our record has not been stellar
we have enacted some renewable tax
incentives but for budgetary reasons
those were enacted for only short
periods of time often they were allowed
to expire before we got around to
renewing them as an example the most
significant tax incentive that we've
enacted to encourage alternative energy
development has been the renewable
energy production tax credit in the case
of wind energy this credit provides a a
reimbursement of nearly 2 cents per
kilowatt hour for electricity produced
from a wind turbine for a full 10 years
after that turbine is put into service
problem has been that the period during
which one's required to put the turbine
in service in order to receive the
credit those periods were relatively
short we have a chart that shows how
this problem is played out the problem
is illustrated u.s. wind capacity
additions each year are reflected on
this chart in years when the production
tax credit was fully available there was
robust development in years when the tax
credit was scheduled to expire financial
institutions were reluctant to invest in
projects that were not certain to be
producing before the expiration of the
credit the result obviously was a boom
and bust cycle that you can see on the
chart clearly a more consistent tax
policy would have put us much further
along in this development and use of
wind power government-driven boom and
bust cycles in the wrong message to
entrepreneurs what we need is a way to
provide long term market stability for
renewable electricity production part of
that solutions to provide a long-term
extension of the tax credits for
renewable electricity and I do believe
that Congress will next year with a new
administration in office finally pass
much longer-term extension of these tax
credits the fifth and final area that
I'll mentioned today is the need to
claim the economic benefits from clean
tech manufacturing first we need to
acknowledge at least in theory that it's
possible to meet the energy challenges
I've outlined without creating the
domestic manufacturing capability and
the domestic manufacturing jobs that
ought to go with that to use the current
buzzword we unfortunately could wind up
outsourcing that manufacturing
particularly through our own inaction
advanced energy storage devices
thin-film photovoltaic cells highly
efficient light emitting diodes all of
these and much more will be needed for
clean efficient energy production and
use but there's no assurance these
products will be produced in the United
States in fact some would argue that
unless we adopt substantial changes in
the way we do business it's more likely
than not that they will not be produced
here that we will buy these products
from abroad in their 1990 book the
breakthrough illusion professors Richard
Florida and Martin Kenney state quote
although the commonplace impression that
breakthrough innovations create
permanent advantage for American
companies may once have been true it is
just not the case anymore a new
realities upon us the u.s. makes the
breakthroughs while other countries
especially Japan provide the
follow-through
now they wrote that 18 years ago today I
believe their statement is truer than
ever the other countries include many
other countries besides Japan here's a
chart that shows what's happened to
world production of photovoltaic cells
since 1995 it's interesting to observe
that and until 1998 we were reasonably
holding our own we weren't getting ahead
of anyone but we were reasonably holding
our own in the
last decade though while production in
other countries has soared the u.s.
photovoltaic industry has remained
stagnant and once again point out that
this is part of a larger problem of our
declining manufacturing base here's a
chart showing the drop-off in US
manufacturing jobs just during the last
seven years this is not just in energy
related technologies this is in all
sectors a strategy to revitalize US
manufacturing the topic of another
speech such a strategy will require
developing a consensus on changes in our
tax policy procurement policy trade
policy probably health policy and
education policy as well we have a real
opportunity now I believe to grow a
high-tech renewables manufacturing base
if we commit to the right policies we
have the knowledge we have the
technology we have the workforce we have
the drive to make all that possible
Germany has proven that such a
transformation can occur in an in an
advanced economy there are nearly
250,000 renewable energy jobs that have
been created in Germany in recent years
and that's expected to grow to at least
400,000 by 2020 imagine what is possible
in an economy of our size and our
capabilities tackling the policy
challenges in the five major areas I've
discussed is important for all of us in
this room or we wouldn't be here on a
Friday afternoon when the weather is
great but as students and researchers
and and innovators today some of you may
be wondering how does all this relate to
students here at MIT let me suggest the
following each of the problems as I said
before present great opportunity as well
as being problems I'm told that mi Stu
MIT students know the connection between
problems and opportunities better than
anyone and you at MIT have a critical
role to play in solving our energy
because of your knowledge and your
abilities and your persistence it's you
who will likely emerge as the leaders in
helping meet this global challenge
re-engineering the way the world
produces stores distributes and uses
energy may in fact be the greatest
challenge that we as a global community
must face together to my mind it is a
very worthy calling addressing the
energy challenges will require
governments industry scientists and
engineers to work together I hope that
some of you will come to Washington to
help us structure the policies and
programs that will facilitate this work
as it happens to graduates of this
university are with me today and work
with me on the Senate Energy and Natural
Resources Committee Bob Simon who's
director of our majority staff is right
here
Alicia Jackson who just graduated last
year with a PhD here at MIT is is also
with me and she's a triple AAS fellow
working with our committee while some of
you may choose to make contributions
through government service many others
will make your mark on our future energy
system through direct research and
innovation as a boniva Bush a former MIT
vice president and scientific advisor to
presidents Roosevelt and Truman said
without scientific progress no amount of
achievement in other directions can
ensure our health and prosperity and
security as a nation in the modern world
so the prospect for all of you to make a
global difference is tremendous your
enthusiasm and commitment to these
issues is extremely encouraging and you
have my pledge that I'll do all I can to
be sure that you have the resources and
support and the policies in place to
achieve success thank you very much
[Applause]
the senator will welcome questions their
microphones in the aisle if to step to
the microphones in the aisle and I will
see the podium back to you thank you
very much for that incredibly insightful
posing of the energy challenge and a
roadmap to help us address it I think I
must answered all the questions well I
should have perhaps been more explicit
about that obviously I think at least
half of the solution has to be more
efficient use of energy and at least
half of the technological progress that
we need to make is is how we can improve
the efficiency with which we we use
energy produce energy and use energy
both so so I think that that
conservation is absolutely central
speech I might say the problem was put
very precisely one question I have is do
you have any suggestions and how do you
change how we measure growth that if you
think growth is measured in terms of how
much energy a country consumes in terms
of the rate of construction in terms of
then when everything is measured against
the rate of energy consumption what do
you have what's what's in place the
Congress has in terms of changing the
way our country is measured in terms of
how its growing most of most of the
measurements that I'm aware of about the
growth rate in the country are not tied
to how much energy were using they're
they're tied to two other factors the
the gross domestic product and
the amount of goods we goods and
services sold and purchased so I don't
know that maybe I'm maybe there's a
place where we are we are tying
ourselves to the amount of use of energy
which I'm just not I'm not familiar with
with where we're doing that and making
policy on the basis of it yes please yes
this one and could you go into more
detail as to why Japan pulled ahead but
us you know Seyed steady weight from my
understanding us is you know has so many
the advanced technology you know it's
made so many the event advanced
advancements in photovoltaic said why is
it that Japan pulled ahead as a u.s.
light behind I I don't have with me
today a itemized list of the various
policies that they adopted but I think
they did have a very proactive set of
policies that they adopted to encourage
both the manufacturer of photovoltaic
cells but also the use of photovoltaic
cells in Japan and some of those were in
their tax tax code some of those who are
were other policies that they adopted we
can try to get that for you but I think
I think there was clearly a an effort by
the government to a recognition that
this was a growing sector of high-tech
manufacturing that they wanted to have a
major part in and they adopted policies
to ensure that that's also been back
with data and PowerPoint slides thanks
oh okay yes senator Bingaman you
expressed a great optimism for our
technological advancement but I was
curious to what extent behavioral
changes you see as being necessary to be
able to meet our energy challenges
well obviously to the extent we can
achieve or see some behavioral changes
that would be good I I think that there
can be some increased recognition in the
general population of the importance of
trying to conserve energy the importance
of trying to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions and that can have a
substantial effect over a period of time
I think it has an effect more in causing
people to buy more fuel-efficient
vehicles and causing people to purchase
homes that are more energy efficient to
do a variety of things I think the
unfortunate reality is that in this
country as in most countries in the
world the the behavioural change is
pretty much driven by economic factors
to a large extent if we put a cap and
trade system in place and the cost of
energy goes up as a result that will
drive behavioural change and that's just
sort of the way that most humans respond
yes with the recent increases in food
prices there have been some suggestions
that are focused on ethanol fuel has
contributed to that rise what are your
thoughts on this issue and more broadly
you know how our energy policy can shift
without you know causing these
unforeseen impacts well my thought is
quite frankly I think we need to we need
to closely monitor this this issue and
and study it and try to make a
determination as to whether the policies
we are adopting and have adopted with
regard to increase biofuels increase use
of biofuels are adversely affecting us
in other ways I I think frankly that we
did not have good information on that
issue when we when we legislated this
last year and increase the requirements
the required use of biofuels I think
many of the people who are now coming
forward and saying that the that the
skyrocketing price of food is is a
result of
increased use of biofuels also don't
have very good information so I think
well I think the jury's still out on
whether or not we've we've overstepped
there so I'm open to having someone
really do a objective analysis of it I
don't think we've seen one yet I had the
pleasure of asking this question to the
Secretary of Energy a couple weeks ago
and I figured to ask another person from
Washington be sure and tell me what he
said before I have to answer so as you
mentioned given that the energy
challenge is a global challenge and that
the policies that you mentioned here are
funded by American taxpayers what should
be done to transfer the technology to
the countries that need it and the
secretary unfortunately said you
couldn't give me an answer
he didn't get he didn't give you any
answer well I think it's uh you know I
think that obviously that's a very
important and complex question I think
we we are one of the best ways we can
deal with the problem of greenhouse gas
emissions is to transfer whatever
technology is developed to deal with
that problem transfer it as broadly and
widely and quickly as possible that
doesn't mean that we can't we can't
continue to benefit from having
developed that technology and but I
think the United States unfortunately
has not played the leadership role it
should in coming to grips with these
problems worldwide and I think that we
have a great opportunity to do that and
I hope that that happens beginning this
next year and and I think part of that
opportunity is to be sure that as we
develop technologies that we know work
where we're seeing to it that those
become available particularly in less
developed parts of the world
senator I believe both you and president
Hockfield spoke on how America in the
recent years has been falling behind the
rest of the world in science and
technology and I believe that this is
largely due to the deteriorating quality
of math and science education and public
schools coming from a public school here
in America myself I can attest to this
fact and what plans do you and your
colleagues in the Senate have to deal
with this issue well first I agree with
you that that that's one area and
obviously this report that both
president Hockfield and I alluded to
from the National Academies I think
they're I think the the first concern
that they identified there was the lack
of focus on math and science education
in the country and and called for a
substantial increase in federal support
federal funding to assist schools and
school districts and states and
upgrading the quality of training more
teachers who are qualified to teach
those courses so they have a whole
series of things that they recommended
the challenge now to us in Congress and
and to the next administration is to
actually go forward and start providing
the funds and do so on a consistent
basis to begin begin correcting this
deficiency thank you uh-huh senator I
appreciate your optimism and all the
things you're doing to help particularly
in the southwest where we have actually
a strong surplus of sunlight recently
I'm wondering though if you're aware of
why Japan and particularly Germany have
had such a huge growth 57% of all the
solar PV in the world for the last five
years has been shipped to Germany with
27% shipped to Japan even that made in
the u.s. in fact most of the PV that we
make right here Massachusetts goes to
Germany it's already pre-sold and that's
because they have very high feed-in
tariffs so around 55 cents a kilowatt
hour in Germany and
similar not quite as I and in Japan but
also equally high now in Spain and Italy
the United States has had a special
investment tax credit of 30 percent for
renewable energy technologies which runs
out this year and I know last week the
Senate passed a bill extending the PTC
for wind turbines by one year and they
tried to get an extension on their
investment tax credit but our president
has said he will veto any bill that even
gives one penny of money to renewable
energy at the expense of the 18 billion
dollars that he wants to be sure it goes
to the oil companies is this a problem
that we can drill our way out of or
maybe think outside of the barrel well
you you you obviously summed it up well
the you know the problem this gets a
little arcane I guess but the problem
comes down to pay-go rules in Congress
once the Democrats took charge we
reinstate it what we call pay-go rules
which say if you're going to cut taxes
you're gonna have to find an offset to
pay for it and so our proposal to extend
these tax credits for renewable energy
was offset by that 18 billion dollars
that we were getting by reducing the tax
benefits that are going to the oil and
gas industry so that's that's what we
tried to do the administration's
position is is basically that they they
do not want to see any reduction in tax
benefits to own gas industry but they
also do not want to see any offset for
the cost of extending these these tax
credits I think that the next thing
you'll see in Congress is we will we
will be passing at least through the
Senate a a version of these tax cuts our
tax provisions renewable tax provisions
that are not offset in any way and just
add it to the deficit and I think that's
perfectly acceptable with the
administration well we have about
270,000 jobs at stake including a lot of
them ray
here in this state where we're hoping to
make this a major player in the
renewable energy industry so I hope that
you can do something to try and get
these you know we may not need the
incentives and benefits for a long time
but they're very critical now no I agree
with you and I think what will happen
almost certainly or not not almost
certainly but likely is that we will
pass them for a short period of time to
get into the next administration
probably unpaid for and then once we're
into the next administration hopefully
we'll find a way to act in my view more
responsibly and actually find a way to
offset the cost of making them
substantially longer yes hi senator and
a very popular phrase these days is
energy independence and a lot of a lot
of the presidential candidates are
continuously talking about energy
independence some how good it is and
what's your view on it and is it a
desirable goal for this country to do
the team well it's not a it's not a near
term meaning the next few decades it's
not an achievable goal I think we we are
about 60% of our oil comes from overseas
today and it will take a substantial
period here for us to develop the
alternatives develop the technologies to
wean ourselves off of that so I think
energy independence is certainly a
worthwhile goal but it is a very distant
goal and I think realistically over the
next couple of decades I would be very
pleased if we could see a reduction in
the amount of oil we're importing if we
could actually see significant shifting
toward use of hybrid plug-in hybrid
vehicles other ways to avoid the need
for so much oil yes
through most of your talk I see the
focus on growth of renewable energies of
increase in research or efficiency but
how far are you willing to go or are you
able to go to actually pass legislation
that reduces things like the quality of
life or that we have to actually just
stop driving our cars as much not build
hybrid cars so we can keep driving
is it even at all possible that we are
willing to step back in the things that
we can do in our you know ways of
spending that's you're willing to do it
like in Congress say okay you just
cannot drive that much anymore well
since this is a representative form of
government we've got people who pass
laws saying you can't drive anymore
aren't aren't usually they're too long
so I do think that there are there are
ways that we can adopt policies though
that will create incentives for people
to find ways to reduce their energy
consumption this cap-and-trade proposal
is intended to do just that
it's intended to to result in in a lot
of people looking at what is the extent
of my energy consumption is are there
ways I can reduce it and I think that's
a much better way to go than then for
Congress to be trying to legislate
specifically you can't do this you can't
do that you can't do the other now I
think there are you know the
requirements that we put on on
automobile manufacturers anyone who
wants to sell a vehicle and this in this
market needs to improve their vehicle
fuel efficiency I think that's something
we clearly need to be doing what are you
willing to go as far to pass legislation
that reduces our quality of life or the
amount of jobs that we have or is that
as every progress have to be forward
well I think it's as I say I don't think
you're gonna find
the majority of the Congress in support
of legislation that is intended to
reduce the quality of life that's just
not not a good campaign platform I
haven't noticed any of the presidential
candidates running on that platform and
I doubt that we will see that yes
Sanders thank you very much for bringing
up the past thirty years of history of
failed projects in the clean energy
transportation which I found it's very
insightful and also very ironic that
that has happened so I was thinking
about a Department of Energy which were
which you mentioned in today's
presentation and which worries about the
clean energy and also the Department of
Transportation which I actually don't
think you mentioned today which worries
about transportation and is it a problem
that we have Department of
Transportation which worries about
transportation we have Department of
Energy which worries about something
else and there is nobody who no central
authority which worries about clean
energy transportation it is a some
restriction that we need to create to to
make it happen well you're right that we
have we tend to compartmentalize some of
these things in ways that are
unfortunate I do think that that's
that's part of the reason why I think it
would make more sense in these areas of
technology development to to have more
authority at the at the level of the
president's science advisor and and have
have a coordinating function occur there
so it wouldn't wouldn't depend upon
whether it's in the Department of Energy
or the department transportation there
would be one policy in both departments
would be trying to implement it thank
you
okay one more question yes I you said
that you wouldn't address design of cap
and trade but I can still ask about it I
suppose so I was wondering first have
you learned anything specifically from
what Europe is on with ETS mistakes or
successes they've had and also could you
address which industries in particular
would be included I of course a power
utilities but who else would be under
the umbrella of
kathan trade well I think we are in the
process of trying to learn about the
mistakes and problems that were
encountered in Europe and their ETS
there are emissions trading scheme as
they call it the frankly they they have
just started on January 1st of this year
the second phase of the ETS and they're
they're trying to determine whether or
not it's structured the way it should be
or not at this point I think we're
trying to determine the same thing I
think they made quite a few mistakes in
the first phase of their ETS they they
first of all gave out too many
allowances they didn't have good based
baseline data on the amount of emissions
that was we're occurring there were a
whole bunch of things that they did
wrong at the first and they readily
admit that but they were they were sort
of learning as they went we're trying to
learn before we enact something and and
avoid that as best we can what was the
second part of your question which
industries would be included beyond the
utilities well my preference would be to
include as much of the economy as
possible I think trying to put a system
in place that is economy-wide is though
is the way to start and I hope we were
able to do that and that gets into a lot
of political arguments in the next 10
years what's that well actually be
passed in the next 10 years there's no
hope no I think it will because we have
three candidates for president all of
whom are committed to the to the
enactment of a cap-and-trade system I
don't think it'll pass this year but I
do think that we'll have a good debate
about it in jet in June in the Senate
and maybe make some progress toward
getting a piece of legislation that then
will give us a starting point for going
into the next administration I think in
the next couple of years we will enact a
cap-and-trade system that's my my guess
thank you Thanks
I want to thank Senator Bingaman on
behalf of all of us in MIT for sharing
his insights with us today but probably
more important for the work he does
every day and advocating for great
policies that support research and
development that move us to that bright
clean energy future to which we all
dream thank you senator
[Applause]